this is a school not a circus that's a  quote from a school board in Ontario  Canada after joining students in  protests of a trans teacher who has  large breasts let's show it uh Anthony  you can see nipple well that's what they  said they were saying like you know the  rule is you can't show any nipples in  the school they can't be exposed and I  see their point okay listen jrbp is  pro-trans we are allies we are  supportive do your thing let your flag  fly but this you're gonna get some  comments no matter what when you're  working in high school and those are  bazungus is there fake boobs that you  can buy at like a s m or fetish store  they put that on in the morning to go to  work yeah that's even crazier I know I  would call it a circus but there's some  juggling going on those breasts showed  up in one car she also happens to be  like a machine shop teacher then that's  a hazard that's getting in the way of  something